[Music]
well I don't think there are in
Tennessee but actually their rule
[Music]
today I'm going to ask my British
Council teacher to see that already
interesting have you ever accepted to
friend requests from people you don't
know
never how often you post photo of
yourself on social every day once or
twice a week once a year I never checked
your email bank accounts with using a
public would think even when it tells
you it's not secure ok I have to tell
you yes yeah I know I shouldn't but yes
have you ever checked in to somewhere on
social media sentiment yes I checked but
I usually don't check myself through
several credit cards debit cards
information decide before or never never
never no no I don't like to I bought
once this website now next time it was
there
[Music]
[Music]
have you ever used the word password or
want to support as before no I try to
add something difficult to fathom
originally to make it a little bit more
challenging yeah
- do you use the same passwords I use
the same eye you can try to avoid site
information avoid taking information
good but it's not good enough you know
an account is active every 39 seconds
63% of the use is because someone
managed to get password I don't know are
you gonna change password on everything
thank you for watching make sure to stay
safe online and that's wrong
[Music]